hi I'm the barn grandson of the team should
privilege in Brazil and in the debate
today
Let's see how to get started
fragments your android projects and
after all what are the fragments
Fragments are a behavior or a
the user interface area of ​​a
tivit you can combine several of these
fragments on a single tivit riding
so a multi-panel interface is not
use of the fragments also allows
the use of the code
you can get this same behavior
this same piece of cte 20 and use
other activities or even in other
applications that you develop
this feature has been running since
android 3.0 honeycomb that was when
started the part of the tablets officially
the android and at that point we had to
create some support so that you
could have a more fluid interface than
would work best on large screens and
also on smartphones
the fragments then allow the
application has an interface that
adapt to each situation the size
without you have to develop a
specific code a certain situation
as the classic example here is in the
screen that is from a list where when you
click on this list it takes you to a
next screen usually a new one that
I had with the details of this element that
You clicked if you want to have
back in the list will select a new one
new selection but do not imagine that you
there's a tablet now I know you're going
then put a list of seven or 10
inches you can use the space better
how do we do it using
panel layout yesterday on the left
list panel and on the right the details
this time with the Flemish I click on a
list it updates the details to the
right
this is the most practical example
classic in the use of flagrant
we have several other examples
that it is also worth giving a
I have to justify and
eg compress where you set the
left width so that you do not
has a balanced interface with the
size of the right and also has here the
battery
where are you going to stack the panels
fragments according to the orientation of the
Sodré will quote and so you enjoy
better the space of your business
also has the part to expand and
collect where unlike the young kit
before scut will expand collect
showing more or less information
relevant to the size of the
brings left panel hold there
the right panel and also has the
show hide where sometimes even
on a tablet but it does not stay legal on
show mode the left panel
gets very flat they end up losing a
identity
then you hide the part of the
left shows part that is right
full screen and allows the user to
go back to previous screen using gay pv
chan, for example, and you have to take
mind when we are going to design a
multi-panel interface the first point
plan ahead as your ep
will behave on different screens
guidelines
then draw an interface design one
mockup plans that you do not get caught
surprise
another thing identifies way more
suitable for composing the screens
reorganizing the panels when you change the
do not think it's just that you have a
tablet or have a screen phone
greater is to place a larger stiffening design
to the same place does not think how
make better use of this space
more comfortable for your user
We also have to look for
opportunities to consolidate screens in
many panel compositions ie
suddenly a tablet of 7 where 10 or
your nexus 41 phone by the smaller you
you can end up joining two screens in one
only and with possible more comfortable interface
and more fluid user and law enforcement
end
make sure your cells offer
the same features when they are in
different rotations or sizes
many different
for example if you are accessing a
party functionality resolves to
screen and at that point a feature
add at this moment that is one thing
always try to offer the same
group of features when you have
working with these different
parliaments
Let's now see what the
steps for us to create a fragment
first thing then is to create
the class descending from fragment
then to define a layout that will be
used
you use to program about writing the
method a customer has seen and this is indeed is
the only method you really
need to develop to have your movie
working
the other life cycle methods also
are important but you can implement
them later
according to your needs.
functions and characteristics of your
screen
so I think you've already created if the
Flemish you need to add it
activity
in this case they are modular objects
that work by themselves but you have to
each instance of it is added a
activity in the case of the dreaded pelé
saw it before 11 you use a
fragmented activity that is made available
by free support
then it is possible to associate
a semed layout file with shred
so that you can then mount your
multi-panel interface with personal
let's see now how to work with
front and in this specific example the
People are going to use ego support.
I had the class start right away.
Fragment layout support where they will be
encapsulated all classes
in this example it extends from
fragmente active as I explained
previously it is necessary for you to
can use food with support
hare good here logo 17 content view
I had this and I'm defining layout
let's take a look at that layout
because of the movies that's where it's
defined the use of the films in this first
here we are seeing that there is only one
defined frame and in this case is the
fragments because I'm in portrait mode
In this case, then I will only display the
list does not have because there is another
flagrant when clicking here it will have
another tite who will then show the
Details
in this case a list of
shakespeare after the dialogues goes down
of this part already in this other file
remembering that the same name but now is
saved in layout folder lend trace
landscape I have two elements because
fraud are still on the list that
is on the left and another a frame layout
with the id of yours that is used for the
inclusion of the fragment of the details
with the dialogues
the type you selected in the list
do not have landscape mode
Let's go back here and let's the woman then
in the list class what it is
making
in this case the flame tyton is fragmented and
extends from it is a list of
is normal that it encapsulates some
behaviors have everything to do with
garbage adapts and you can look after
waiting documentation have some
doubt
but the point is the following when I click
in an item I see that no item list
click
I have a show from God that he does it
first check that you have two
panes on the screen or in landscape mode
where I have there are lists that form
right and if I have I'll raise the chicken
again with the details of this dialogue and
I'll look through the dts as far as I can.
20 defined in the layout and I'll make the exchange
put the new fragmente in that layout there
then making the dynamic exchange of
fragments on the screen
if you are in portrait mode that will be
this is what there is a code that
What do I do, Dilma understands and says
to a new activity that is where you
detail can be displayed.
find this class I had here in
our code that shows exactly what
it shows that when creating the class if by
chance you have a landscape mode it
will kill this activity
but why does it all landscape me
I do not have the assets I'm going to use
two panels and I'll use your
fragments down here in the code people
also can see the god fragmente that
nothing else having to display the items
that you submitted to the case was a
dialogue and there are the text and
scroll all right
So what we're seeing here is
I have a list that displays the
items a fragment that will display
update and if you are in
I'm going to have assets that are released
by that same list
good folks in today's episode we
we have seen what the fragments are and some
options for how to combine these
in several panels for its interface
and also how to create layouts for
guidelines and add these
lion
fragments and activities and at the end
we saw how to communicate between two
fragments or start a new
according to the orientation of your
device from now on you
you can start using fragments in
your android projects
this is the debate today and in the next